[Musique]
bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour faire le tour de l'actualité
locale bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
dans cette édition du jeudi 27 mai voici
les titres
le groupe est installé dans la zone
d'activités de coignières et maurepas
depuis près de 30 ans achètent devrait
quitter paris ouest à l'horizon 2026
l'annoncé a été faite au syndicat tout
récemment le site emploie 650 salariés
intérimaires de quoi susciter
l'inquiétude des maires des deux
communes concernées
malgré la crise sanitaire et une baisse
des ventes en 2020 le secteur de
l'immobilier maintient sa dynamique en
ile-de-france et dans les yvelines des
prix en hausse des maisons prises et les
détails à suivre nous recevrons
également cédric laporte youtuber
spécialisés et directeur d'une agence
immobilière à villepreux et puis des
places qui se font rares suite au
réaménagement de la voirie et de la
construction de bâtiments le
stationnement devient de plus en plus
difficiles à guyancourt
face à la colère des habitants la
municipalité a lancé une concertation
sur le sujet elle devrait avoir lieu
d'ici l'été
-a suivre également tout à l'heure la
suite et la fin de notre dossier de la
rédaction consacrée aux archives
départementales des yvelines un lieu
vous le verrez indispensable pour la
recherche
l annonce a été faite il y à peu aux
syndicats le groupe hachette livre va
quitter ses locaux saint quentinois
d'ici 2026 le site installé à paris
ouest une zone d'activités située sur
les communes de maurepas et coignières
emploie actuellement 650 salariés et
intérimaires une nouvelle difficile pour
les maires des deux communes les détails
avec mélanie poker 12 hectares du site
devenu trop petit hachette livre
souhaite s'agrandir ou plutôt se
moderniser et a besoin de 20 hectares
une information transmise il y a un an
aux maires des communes concernées
maurepas et coignières on pouvait pas
sur la communauté d'agglo a
effectivement ça fait un an que l'on
cherche désespérément et un terrain
d'une vingtaine d'hectares on ne l'a pas
on l'a pas on peut tout au plus leur
offrir ce qu'ils ont déjà donc c'est pas
possible
selon eux on a fait avec mon collègue
grigori yaris thiémé maire de maurepas
on a fait effectivement des propositions
d'aménagement de nos élus respectifs
pour qu'ils puissent en ligne elle imite
s'étendre en hauteur 1
donc densifier sur le site il semble que
techniquement ça soit pas possible
le départ serait envisagée à l'horizon
2026 vers allainville défavorable le
maire de coignières souhaite connaître
le futur du terrain dont hachette livre
et le propriétaire vous partez très bien
700 emplois partent et nous on souhaite
une réindustrialisation du site souhaite
un nouveau que ce site revivent et de
l'emploi attire de nouvelles entreprises
voire plusieurs entreprises il ya déjà
douze hectares
donc il ya des possibilités de comment
dire de réindustrialiser le site
alors on leur demandait bien entendu
s'il avait un projet tandis qu'il n'est
pas de projet à l'heure actuelle pour le
site
les entreprises qui demandent à
s'implanter sur 50 ha on est quand même
un territoire innovant on a aujourd'hui
une visibilité
le dire mondial dans les colonnes de la
gazette le groupe hachette indique que
le projet va faire l'objet de plusieurs
procédures de consultation des instances
représentatives du personnel
conformément à la loi et dans le respect
du dialogue social le maire de maurepas
grégory gars restiez n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer à notre micro
un communiqué de presse des deux villes
a été publié le 30 avril dernier dans
l'actualité les maires de la
circonscription de police de plaisir
obtiennent un léger gain de cause un
renfort de quatre policiers
supplémentaires est prévue
annonce du ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin fin avril les élus de
plaisir saint-cyr-l'ecole villepreux les
clayes sous bois bois d'arcy et fontenay
le fleury s'étaient réunis pour une
conférence de presse devant le
commissariat d'arrondissement il déploré
à l'époque de ne pas faire partie des
effectifs supplémentaires annoncées par
le président de la république et 10000
dans toute la france dont 128 pour les
yvelines un déploiement qui ne
concernait pas la circonscription de
plaisir désormais doté donc et d'un
renfort de quatre policiers dans un
contexte particulier le marché de
l'immobilier en ile de france tend à se
maintenir malgré la crise sanitaire et
la baisse des ventes sur un an près 260
mille logements ci ont été vendus en
2020 dans la région un niveau au dessus
de la moyenne des biens vendus sur les
dix dernières années et les prix eux ont
augmenté d'environ 5,1 pour cent entre
février 2020 et février 2021
une tendance qui est similaire dans le
département des yvelines les détails de
nicolas landry les yvelines le
département où le nombre de ventes est
le plus important dans la grande
couronne plus de vingt mille logements
anciens vendus en 2020 53 % des ventes
réalisées le sont pour des appartements
47% pour des maisons concernant les
ventes d'appartements le prix médian
atteint 215 milles euros pour les
maisons c'est plus élevé puisque la
médiane dépasse les 365 milles euros
principal enseignement 1 par rapport au
facteur prix dans l'immobilier c'est sa
forte augmentation une hausse plus
importante pour les maisons achetées
dans les yvelines puisqu'ils ont
augmenté de 6,8 pour cent en un an pour
les appartements le prix au mètre carré
a grimpé de 4 6%
un constat est clair sur le territoire
il ya une disparité de prix en fonction
des arrondissements du départ
en prenons l'exemple des maisons vendues
à saint-germain-en-laye elle dépasse les
500 mille euros celle de mantes-la-jolie
sont moitié moins cher soit deux cent
cinquante mille euros
le phénomène d'augmentation des prix de
l'immobilier peut s'expliquer à la fois
par les taux d'intérêt qui sont bas qui
facilite l'accès au prêt pour une
acquisition immobilière un phénomène
engendré aussi par la crise sanitaire et
les confinements successifs
aujourd'hui les acquéreurs recherchent
surtout une maison avec jardin et pour
parler de ce sujet cédric la porte est
avec nous par visioconférence bonsoir
bonsoir youtuber de l'immobilier sur
votre chaîne vous proposer des vidéos
pour aider les agents à performer dans
leur métier vous êtes aussi à la tête
d'une agence immobilière a dit le pr le
constat qui a été fait dans la chronique
précédente est ce que vous le faites
aussi à l'échelle de votre agence à à
vil prix à savoir des ventes à la baisse
en 2020 des prix qui augmentent est-ce
que c'est aussi des choses que vous avez
constaté plus localement oui tout à fait
donc un marché bouleversé avec la crise
sanitaire et au premier confinement on a
constaté donc un arrêt total des
transactions immobilières ça a été
l'incertitude tout le monde se poser la
question de ce qui allait devenir
l'immobilier dans les mois et les années
à venir
et finalement au premier déconfinement
eh bien on a pu constater un regain
énorme pour la pierre et surtout ce que
vous avez noté c'est une demande
particulière pour les maisons plus de 60
% + 70% même de demande de maisons
donc c'est colossal il ya eu un autre
un autre point qui a attiré aussi les
futurs propriétaires les candidats à
l'acquisition
vous vous en doutez peut-être grégory
c'est la demande d'un espace pour
télétravailler on pense que ça va ça va
également bouleversé l'immobilier dans
les mois et les années à venir
cette demande d'avoir un espace
complémentaire dans la maison pour
pouvoir effectuer de nouvelles demandes
des espaces de télétravail aussi des
maisons avec jardin on voit aussi que
les yvelines est un département qui a la
cote parmi les départements de la grande
couronne si on regarde les ventes en
2020 est ce que c'est une tendance qui a
toujours existé ou
justement avec la crise sanitaire et
peut-être l'envié aussi de fuir les
villes justement le département des
yvelines c'est un bon compromis entre
l'urbain et la campagne puisque c'est un
département qui a un pied dans les deux
dans l'urbain et dans la campagne
tout à fait et c'est un département qui
reste très vert où il fait bon vivre
c'est vrai que les vignes dans les
yvelines sont quand même très très très
agréable donc je suis pas surpris de ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on constate déjà
depuis quelques années les evènes il
attire de plus en plus on a quand même
un niveau d'un seuil de sécurité qui est
quand même plus élevé qu une grande un
grand nombre de départements dans la
petite et la grande couronne parisienne
donc non c'est tout à fait normal mais
je pense que ça va s'accélérer
effectivement avec toute cette partie
toute cette verdure qu'on a dans les
yvelines
et vu que les gens sont dans plus de
plus en plus en quête de sens en quête
de verdure en quête d'espacé bien on
pourra peut-être avoir un regard
effectivement vers vers notre
département c'est la proximité aussi
avec paris on est on est pas loin
finalement de la capitale oui bah ça
c'est et puis bon on va de plus en plus
vers des transports en commun je
l'espère en tout cas facile à utiliser
avec tes des usages plus plus rapide
donc là après ça c'est une vraie
question aussi deuxième est ce que les
gens vont de plus en plus avoir besoin
d'aller sur paris pour travailler avec
cette commande
cette refonte un peu du du travail avec
de plus en plus de télétravail donc on
voit de plus en plus de personnes dans
des clients ou dans les personnes autour
de nous dans nos amis qui nous disent
que voilà ils ont deux trois jours de
télétravail
il se pose réellement la question est
bien de continuer à travailler sur une
grande ville donc c'est vrai que ça
c'est ça fait partie des grands des
grandes mutations qu on a pu constater
ces derniers mois sur le marché
immobilier lennar questions sur ce
marché l'immobilier donc on parle aussi
de la profession d'agent immobilier qui
a forcément évolué avec la crise
sanitaire on a vu aussi à une tendance
avec des prix qui grimpent 1 selon les
maisons +6 8% en moyenne pour les
maisons plus 4,6 pour cent pour le prix
au mètre carré des appartements
comment on peut l'expliquer
nicolas landry de tv 68 expliqué qu' il
y avait peut-être une explication à
chercher dans les taux d'intérêt qui
sont bas en ce moment il ya d'autre
explication peut-être oui alors les les
éléments principaux qui explique cette
augmentation des prix c'est que il ya eu
c'est ce phénomène où on sait les gens
se sont retrouvés enfermés chez eux il
ya eu un besoin de consommer je pense
après le premier confinement et c'est là
on a on a eu une explosion du nombre de
visites et peu de mises en vente
malheureusement c'est ce qui fait que
les prix immobiliers ont augmenté peu de
d'offres et beaucoup de demandes on a
senti que les gens avaient vraiment
besoin de ne consommer et d'avoir
quelque chose de plus grand de profiter
de la vie donc je pense que ce sont les
éléments principaux types de phénomènes
et finalement quand on regarde par
rapport à 2010 9 c'est déjà une année
qui était un record en termes
d'immobilier l'année 2020 at elle
vraiment plus que résister à vue que
vous dites dans les yvelines
on a eu encore une augmentation donc on
n'est pas surpris de ça donc vraiment le
phénomène principal je pense que c'est
ce besoin aussi de verdure d'air et donc
de sens que les gens va leur donner dans
l'acquisition immobilière une deuxième
thématique que je souhaite aborder avec
vous cédric la porte la crise sanitaire
on l'imaginé a aussi eu des conséquences
sur le métier d'agent immobilier des
répercussions forcément la donne a
changé en un an il ya des ondes à dire
des modes de travail qui est qui ont
changé pour pour la profession d'agent
immobilier
oui tout à fait alors la profession
était déjà très en retard sur la
digitalisation donc là clairement ça a
été un accélérateur phénoménale et
également les notaires un vus qui a des
crêtes est sorti en avril 2020 donc
juste après le début de la crise
sanitaire pourrait bien fluidifier le
marché avec les signatures à distance
bouclé signature électronique les
agences immobilières avait déjà un petit
peu pris le pas mais elle sait sont mis
de plus en plus donc on a eu de plus en
plus de vision avec les clients a eu de
plus en plus de signature électronique
annonce qu'il y ait des contrats des
mandats mais également et bien les
compromis de vente directement
en com comment le fait là en
visioconférence il ya eu de plus en plus
du dématérialisé dématérialisation
pardon des outils des professionnels de
l'immobilier
et ce a également beaucoup changé les
visiteurs je pense que celui-ci voulait
rentrer à grégory comment on fait quand
on peut plus faire visiter de biens
immobiliers et bien le premier
déconfinement a emmené les agents
immobiliers vers la visite virtuelle ce
qui était ce qui existait déjà mais
c'est vrai qu'elle était plutôt réservé
à les produits haut de gamme et on la
voyait pleut peut finalement dans des
villes moyennes avec des prix moyens et
là ça s'est vraiment démocratisé depuis
la visite virtuelle qui a eu beaucoup
d'impact et également les réseaux
sociaux naturellement sur les
négociateurs sont là pour or un travail
de démarchage entre guillemets ils vont
rechercher des prospects et clients et
comment est ce qu'on fait quand on peut
qu rencontrer les gens dans la rue chez
eux
eh bien on va là où est leur attention
c'est à dire sur les réseaux sociaux
les agents immobiliers se sont mis
vraiment à la page ils sont venus des
influenceurs ça veut dire oui justement
mais je rebondis sur ce terme
d'influenceurs le métier d'agent
immobilier tant vers cette tendance soit
influenceurs c'est un mot touriste ans
qui est à la mode en ce moment il doit
tendre vers ça utiliser les réseaux
sociaux ça c'est incontournable
aujourd'hui pour la profession oui tout
à fait on dit souvent qu'on a quelques
années de retard par rapport aux états
unis même si on fait pas tout comme les
états unis on se rend bien compte
aujourd'hui que vous avez des agents
immobiliers aux états unis qui ont
carrément une équipe complète avec un
réalisateur un caméraman et un preneur
de sons autour d'eux pour créer du lien
en finalement avec les les particuliers
on n'est pas uniquement des personnes
qui ouvre des portes ou qui faisons des
estimations on crée du lien avec les
gens et si vous voulez on a besoin d'eux
les gens ont besoin d'avoir une forme de
confiance vis-à-vis des agents
immobiliers ce qui permet finalement
cette confiance eh bien c'est la vidéo
en plus que des écrits
wood casse je crois que ce soir la vidéo
nous permet vraiment de montrer nos
valeurs de montrer qui nous sommes en
tant qu'agent immobilier est ce qu'il va
faciliter finalement le choix des des
particuliers et on vous retrouve
notamment cédric la porte sur votre page
youtube qui porte votre nom cédric la
porte pour des vidéos un consacré à
l'immobilier merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous et je le rappelle vous êtes
également à la tête d'une agence un qui
est située à villepreux une agence
immobilier dans l'actualité également le
stationnement devient de plus en plus
difficile dans certains quartiers de
guyancourt des places qui se réduisent à
la suite d'aménagements de la voir et de
la construction de bâtiments une
situation incompréhensible pour certains
habitants face à leur colère la mairie a
décidé de lancer une grande concertation
autour du stationnement astrid bergère
et les voix de nicolas d'andré de
bixente hommes et 1 mais rien senti
steban le stationnement devient de plus
en plus difficiles à guyancourt
récemment certains administrés ont reçu
des contraventions alors qu'ils étaient
garés devant chez eux comme à leur
habitude des changements qu'ils ne
comprennent pas ils n'ont pas hésité à
protester sur les réseaux sociaux les
voitures garées dans les rues de bouvier
ont toutes été verbalisé ce matin alors
que la réglementation ou le plan de
voirie n'a pas changé depuis plus de dix
ans j'avoue ne pas comprendre être
sidéré par cette démarche
j'ai reçu ça aujourd'hui sur ma voiture
au boulevard mozart à guyancourt
merci monsieur le maire où est la
solidarité en cette période de crise une
pétition a également été lancés par les
habitants du boulevard mother clé place
devant nos maisons ont été supprimées et
nous ne pouvons nous garer devant notre
domicile sous peine de verbalisation
nous vous demandons de réétudier votre
réglementation concernant les places de
stationnement boulevard mozart c'est
bien à la suite des différents
aménagements de la voirie mais aussi de
l'arrivée de nouveaux immeubles que le
manque de places de stationnement s'est
fait ressentir
y'a plus en plus de construction il ya
plus en plus de monter l
moi je me souviens quand on est réussie
en 83
éric deschamps face aux sollicitations
et aux plaintes des habitants la mairie
a décidé d'engager une grande
concertation autour du stationnement
la première étape est est en cours
puisque je vais sur l'ensemble des sites
j'ai dénombré jusqu'à présent 32 sites
que je vais rencontrer ces rencontres
devraient avoir lieu d'ici
l'été parallèlement un cabinet d'études
spécialisé va être mandatés c'est
important d'avoir un regard extérieur de
professionnels pour nous dire aussi où
nous confirmer nos intentions et je
referai un retour j'espère avant l'été
sinon plus tard à la rentrée pour voir
les mesures à prendre d'ici à la fin de
la concertation la mairie a demandé à la
police municipale de limiter la
verbalisation aux situations
véritablement dangereuse ou
contraignantes
suite et fin à présent dans ce journal
de notre série sur les archives
départementales des yvelines toute cette
semaine nous vous faisions découvrir ce
lieu qui est installé à montigny le
bretonneux depuis 2003 pour les utiliser
au quotidien des historiens des
chercheurs des étudiants tout le monde
en somme peut y aller et se plonger dans
la mémoire du territoire et ugly noir
eléonore sinoquet astrid bergère ont
rencontré sur place un retraité qui
vient de rambouillet c'est le dernier
épisode de ce dossier historien
enseignant chercheur ou bien curieux ont
tous genres
n'importe qui peut consulter et utiliser
les archives
créée en 1794 les archives
départementales des yvelines vieux
souvent méconnus regorge d'informations
pour qui voudrait se plonger dans
l'histoire c'est le cas de marc vigier
inspecteur académique à la retraite mon
travail de recherche actuellement je
travaille sur la délinquance forestière
dans la forêt de rambouillet au xviiie
siècle
c'est à dire à l'époque de cette forêt
relever du duché perry et donc la forêt
de rambouillet que vous pouvez toujours
aujourd'hui admiré dont vous pouvez
profiter
c'est exactement celle du duché père et
de l'époque plusieurs jours par semaine
depuis le mois d'octobre
marc vigier étudie décrypte et analyse
des documents
cela doit lui permettre de publier une
étude scientifique dans l' ouvrage de la
collection mémoire et documents de
lashari la société d'histoire et
d'archéologie de rambouillet et des
yvelines dont il est membre bénévole
vous avez des kilomètres et des
kilomètres de cartons d'archivés de
notre peuple
un stage est par exemple le fonds de la
maîtrise des eaux et forêt de
rambouillet au xviiie siècle
c'est à peu près de 150 cartons archives
et dans chaque cartons d'archivés
compter à peu près un millier folio
cloud c'est la série b
c'est le volume 2246 de la série b donc
ça vous indique votre celui-là huge à
2246 l'espace et qu'on a c'est
intéressant on fait comme lorsqu'on fait
sa maîtrise ou son doctorat et c c'est à
dire que on lis très attentivement les
inventaires pour savoir très précisément
ce qui vous intéresse
et puis après ça après ça on va à la
pêche et ça peut durer longtemps
sans ce lieu gardien de la mémoire ce
retraité ne pourrait publier
prochainement son étude pour lui
l'archivage est nécessaire une prépa ont
passé six y avait passé documentation il
n'y aurait pas de sujet que j'ai choisi
ce sujet parce que je vis moi même en
lisière de forêt dans mouillé mais j'ai
choisi ce sujet tout simplement parce
que j'ai vérifié qu'il était très table
j'ai publié plusieurs livres j'ai publié
une centaine d'articles scientifiques
c'est énorme et je m'en lasse pas un
outil indispensable donc et que le
chercheur connaît bien ce n'est
évidemment pas la première fois qu'il se
plonge dans les entrailles de la mémoire
il vit noise plus anciennement lorsque
j'étais inspecteur d'académie en
responsabilité c'est grâce à la
documentation que j'ai pu trouver ici
que j'ai rédigé un petit ouvrage sur
l'histoire d'accueil versailles on peut
satisfaire ici une curiosité quasiment
illimitées et une curiosité toujours
aussi affûté pour ce retraité qui compte
bien continuer à passer son temps à
fouiller la mémoire des archives
départementales un mot de musique début
2000 21 la ville de trappes a été touché
par une polémique sur l'islamisme suite
aux propos du professeur de philosophie
didier lemaire pour défendre leur
commune plus de 30 artistes locaux et
des alentours ont pris le micro pour ctr
à un projet musical qui donne la parole
aux jeunes de trappes
interview avec iban au rappeur membres
de ce projet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
roger cetera en fait ils consistent à
réunir plus d'une trentaine d'artistes
de la ville et des villes extérieures
pour la principale cause c'était pour
défendre ce qui a été dit sur trappe on
fait parce qu'on a trouvé que c'était
inadmissible et à chaque fois personne
ne dit rien percer n'diaye bah là on a
voulu montrer que c'est pas une ville
comme les personnes décrivent comme je
suis né ici et tout ce qui a été dit je
n'ai jamais eu un seul faux et on dirait
trappe c'est si pire que autres parents
paient alors que ça rien à voir il m'ya
des communautés de partout il ya toutes
sortes de nationalité ils veulent nous
évite le pour le port du voile mais les
médias se voilera voisin moi ma vie je
l'aimerais toute la ville d'un autre
concours ya eu beaucoup d'histoires ya
eu beaucoup de tristesse et beaucoup de
joie mais en tout cas on n'a pas perdu
la foi mais dans le foot on est tous
ensemble d'entendre tout ça ça nous fait
mal vous étonnez pas qu'après ça finisse
mal leur papa à 6 faudrait qui ravale
notre mentalité est génial être appelée
rempli talent là on est tous des génies
pouvoir faire taire tous ces fachos
c'est important que je suis né ainsi
d'entendre ma ville est critiqué comme
ça mais ma mère alitée
ça l'a touché quand même parce que l'on
vit là tout ce qui a été dit on l'a on
l'a jamais vu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du sport pour refermer ce journal la
fédération française de cyclisme a
dévoilé le nom des premiers athlètes
retenus pour la sélection piste aux jeux
olympiques 2021 de tokyo mathilde gros
sera aligné sur la vitesse individuelle
et le keirin avec une deuxième titulaire
qui sera annoncé prochainement est du
côté des hommes florian gringo
constituera le trio de la vitesse par
équipes
tout comme sébastien vigier ryan hellal
tous deux également engagés dans les
épreuves de vitesse individuelle et de
keirin équipe de france s'entraîne
régulièrement au vélodrome national
installé à saint quentin en yvelines
les jo sont au programme du 28 juillet
au 8 août
et ce à tokyo voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité très
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]